last week we had a leak from a number of
officials which indicated that now
Donald Trump is personally under
investigation which he previously
claimed not to be and previously he
wasn't according to fired at the FBI
director James Comey James Comey
confirmed that he did at some prior
points in time tell Donald Trump no
you're not under investigation right now
but I don't know that it's a good idea
to go public with that because then if
at some point you are under
investigation we would have what's
called a duty to correct or to go public
and say now Trump is under investigation
and after we did that story Pat the
trumpets were emailing me saying David
it's fake news the entire thing comes
from unnamed sources it's from failing
news sites it's all bogus it turns out
that now Donald Trump has admitted to
being under investigation in a tweet
that is as bizarre as it is unusual
perplexing and sort of starting to hint
at the possibility that maybe Donald
Trump is going to fire Deputy Attorney
General Rod Rosenstein which is
something that there's been more and
more speculation about this is the trend
for Trump and Trump is media reports on
something based on a leak Trump is say
it's all fake Trump then confirms it
sometimes inadvertently
the Trump is then say it's all a
witch-hunt it's real now all of a sudden
but it's a witch-hunt
here is Donald Trump's tweet over the
weekend very weird quote I am being
investigated for firing the FBI director
by the man who told me to fire the FBI
director witch hunt so who is the man
who told Trump to fire the FBI director
that Trump is referring to it appears as
though he's referring to assistant
attorney general Rosenstein because
again even though Jeff Sessions the
Attorney General's signature was on that
letter sessions has been portrayed as
not really being that involved in that
recommendation again of course because
Jeff Sessions did recuse himself from
everything related to Russia Rosenstein
also happens to be the guy Pat who
selected former FBI director robert
muller to lead the new investigation
into Trump Russia collusion and
Rosenstein is someone who
could fire Robert Muller so this is now
straight up hostility Patt between
Donald Trump and the guy who can fire
Robert Muller
he probably suspects Rosenstein isn't
going to fire Robert Muller
so he's starting to build the pretext
the sort of negative hostility campaign
against Rosenstein perhaps I mean it's
all just very confusing especially
because yesterday you had Trump's
personal attorney Jay Sekulow going on
all the Sunday morning talk shows and he
was contesting the idea that Trump is
under investigation
yeah which again why is Donald Trump
admitting it if it's not right good it's
just so bizarre latest example of Trump
undermining what his lawyers have been
working on for months in one tweet it's
it's constant constant undermining via
Twitter and over the weekend I thought
there is no way that Donald Trump's
aides and staffers would allow him to
fire rod Rosenstein right I mean it
would just be such obvious obstruction
of justice and then I realized truck
staff can't control him if they could he
wouldn't have been tweeting for the last
few months do you realize that most of
what's going on right now is because of
what Donald Trump has said about the
situation if from day one Donald Trump
said nothing more
whenever anything surfaced in the media
or in a rose garden press conference or
whatever from day one Donald Trump's one
statement was I am fully cooperating
with the investigation I look forward to
being cleared and I will continue to
focus on my campaign priorities
throughout the investigation 90% of what
we are now looking at in terms of
figuring out what there is and isn't
here is because of Donald Trump's public
comments which have fueled the insanity
we wouldn't have any of this if it
weren't for Donald Trump's comments on
Twitter and in interviews and at press
conferences right and as we know from
Watergate it's often more about the
cover-up than it is the actual crime
yeah you just have to wonder if they can
actually pin down obstruction of justice
against him because he has the right to
fire these people yes he does he does
and at this point each firing will be a
bigger and bigger firestorm and I'm
increasingly of the mindset that while
there is very little doubt in my mind
that there was some level of what we
could colloquially call Kalu
you know coordination between Trump and
Russia I'm increasingly thinking that
it's going to be hard to in a legal
sense prove collusion or corruption
between Trump and Russia however at this
point the obstruction case the cover-up
of the entire thing is way more likely
to be what if there isn't undoing to
Donald Trump is responsible for it so
again if Trump had just stayed quiet the
whole time there likely would not have
been anything provable that he did with
Russia I mean maybe some of his campaign
surrogates will it'll come out that
they've colluded with the Russians or
whatever made it's really hard to pin
that down on the candidate himself you
know there's so many people working
below him there could just be enough
plausible deniability to save his
presidency I support the investigation I
will be cleared and I am focusing on my
legislative agenda that would have kept
Trump out of so much of the trouble that
he is now in send me your thoughts I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show great
program today we'll be back after this
today's episode of the show is sponsored
by blue apron you know springtime is a
good time of year to sort of hit the
reset button we tackle personal goals
like getting fit cleaning and cooking is
a good one blue apron makes incredible
home cooking easy and accessible by
delivering seasonal recipes with
step-by-step instructions and my
favorite so you avoid throwing out half
of that garlic bulb that you don't know
what to do with pre-portioned
ingredients all delivered to your door
for under 10 bucks a meal you can also
customize your recipes based on your
preferences you can select delivery days
that are right for your schedule and
there's no commitment so you only get
deliveries when you want them I have
been loving the blue apron recipes that
I've been trying and some of the meals
available in June include warm smoked
trout and asparagus salad with
fingerling potatoes and garlic croutons
spiced zucchini and enchiladas with
creamy lime and tomato rice and a latte
style vegetable tostadas with summer
squash poblano peppers and cilantro rice
you can check out this week's menu get
your first
three meals free with free shipping by
going to blue apron comm slash Pakman
you'll love how good it feels and tastes
to create incredible home-cooked meals
with blue apron so don't wait
blue apron comm slash PA k ma n